uh they're finally getting to the Border
pretty late DHS secretary myar is off to
Eagle Pass Texas to meet with border
patrol Personnel just two days before
the house will hold his first
impeachment hearing over his failures at
the border and ahead of this trip a new
DHS report revealing that more than 2.3
million migrants have been released at
the border under the Biden
Administration thus Cleveland is Sheriff
of teral County Texas and a retired
border patrol agent and he joins me now
thanks so much for being here I just
read that intro a lot of that sounds
like way too little and way way way too
late from the uh DHS secretary what say
you hey good morning Todd and thank you
all for having me you know we continue
to call it a crisis but uh we're well
beyond that it's been pasted that we're
at a catastrophe um what we continue to
see um just when we think it can't get
any worse it continues to get even worse
so you know this is something that I've
said many times it's solvable and uh
you're right the the administration
doesn't want to do anything um we've got
one more year of suffering until we get
a new president until president Trump
comes into office and fixes this now you
were with house Speaker Mike Johnson at
the border on Friday here's what he said
about impeaching May orcus
listen I believe secretary May orcus is
an abject failure but it's not because
of incompetence I believe he has done
this intentionally I think these are
intentional policy decisions that he's
made and I think there must be
accountability for that secretary the
guy you need to negotiate with secretary
mayorcas is not a goodfaith negotiating
partner he is unwilling to enforce
existing federal law why would we
believe that he would do uh any new
provision he's lied to Congress
repeatedly he's lied to me personally
under oath your reaction to what you
just heard the speaker
say completely accurate look I've
watched almost every testimony of
secretary mayorcas going up to the hill
going up to Congress and testifying um
we've all seen it very untruthful um he
ignores the questions answers it the way
he wants to um you know it's it's it's
sad how does this man go back to his
family and uh look him in the eye and
tell him he's doing the best he can do
for the country um is that plain and
simple nobody knows these issues better
than you you were a border patrol agent
you're now a sheriff you're in this area
dealing with this problem on a day in
and day out basis and you told our
producers that sheriffs along the border
are actually divided on the issue of
Border enforcement that really surprised
me what have you found as you speak with
your fellow sheriffs about this
yes sir so again you know I just retired
19 months ago and and I'd still be a
board Patrol agent but unfortunately our
Sheriff passed away Santiago Gonzalez Jr
and uh I'm from this community so I had
the time to retire and I retired and uh
you know I've always looked at at our
partnering sheriffs and we've always had
great relationships along the border but
uh but as this crisis as this
catastrophe has continued to increase um
and in meetings we have emails we shared
um you know you have communities that
are along the border are are primarily
Democratic communities and and those
sheriffs want to to make sure they keep
their constituents happy um you know I
was part of the the Texas border
Sheriff's Coalition and and I withdrew
my membership um because all we do is is
we uh talk through emails and we'll have
maybe a couple meetings a year and uh we
all agree to either disagree or we agree
that the the policies which really there
is no policy with this Administration
alonger border it's a free-for-all and
then we write letters and uh we need
more proactive um processes here along
the border there is one Sheriff Roy Boyd
who you all had on before you know he's
using what the governor's given us
through some funding and created a task
force operational own task force that is
tangible and has produced some some real
security along our border that is one of
the most Illuminating answers that we've
heard so far during this crisis play
that back if you want a real answers to
why it's happening Sheriff thus
Cleveland thank you for what you're
doing and thank you for your time this
morning we appreciate it I'm Steve Ducey
I'm Brian kilme and I'm Angley airheart
and click here to subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most comp ing
analysis